the parents of a University of Maryland
student who died from a virus linked
illness are speaking out about
conditions on the campus freshman Olivia
paragould died last week after
complaining about flu-like symptoms the
18 year old had contracted adenovirus
health officials say they've identified
three new cases in Maryland students now
this is raising concern about mold
problems in the dorms
Jericka Duncan spoke to Olivia's parents
only on CBS this morning she's on the
University of Maryland campus in College
Park Norika I know it well I went there
this is very sad story to hear a good
morning to you good morning absolutely a
tragic very sad story for that family
you know the university officials say
that they hired contractors to clean up
that mold in the dorms now Olivia
parable was one of many students who
complained about it
her parents telling me yesterday that
they believe that that mold contributed
to their child's death we can't imagine
you know having to go and pick out a
plot for your daughter that's not the
way it's supposed to work just three
days ago
Ian and Meg Peres gall buried their
daughter Olivia she was a freshman
studying criminology at the University
of Maryland I think she found a real
place for herself that brings me a lot
of comfort knowing that she she was
finding joy in life olivia was diagnosed
with Crohn's disease before coming to
college and took medication which her
father says weakened her immune system
within weeks of starting school he says
Olivia began expressing concerns about
mold in her dorm room in Elkton hall
because she saw the mold on their shoes
overnight kyle Rumsey is among the
freshman students who told us he also
found mold in his dorm room I would have
red eyes when I'd wake up I have a
scratchy throat the University says it
began receiving higher than normal
reports of mold throughout the dorm
beginning on September 16th
five days later officials began
relocating more than 500 students from
Alton Hall until crews finish cleaning
on October 10th there should have been
greater disclosure and transparency
about the existence of the mold it was
just kind of brushed off
we're gonna clean it and that was the
first issue that was the first issue
university officials say they learned
about their first case of adenovirus on
November 1st
the next day Olivia went to the
University Health Center complaining of
difficulty breathing the Paragon say no
one tested their daughter for adenovirus
they don't kind of connect that one dot
on hmm the student is immunosuppressed
she has all the symptoms of adenovirus
we had a diagnosis of had no virus oh
she just we'll just sent her home
Olivia was eventually treated at John
Hopkins hospital but died on November
18th her parents say doctors told them
if they had known she had ADD no virus
they would have given her a different
treatment something her parents believe
could have saved Olivia's life we've
cried for days and then we go numb and
then we are in disbelief and it's just
no one should have to do this now the
university officials say that there is
no link between AD no virus and mold
they also know that the disease or virus
rather was contracted not just by
students living on campus but also those
living off-campus biana such a tragic
story drink as so many people wondering
how you get meals and mold thrives in
humidity so the advice for consumers at
home is to keep your humidity levels
below 50% if you have water damage make
sure it is checked and it as painful as
this is I'm really glad that the
parables are speaking up because it'll
force other people to take a close look
and really take this more seriously and
mister peres goal is so right a parent
should never have to pick out a plot for
their child when he said that it gave me
chills yeah they never thought they'd be
talking about this when they were
applying nobody does know